l'année enfin on a parlé du paradoxe des
deux enfants savoir cette énigme à
laquelle j'ai proposé deux solutions
convaincantes aux conclusions
contradictoires et je vous ai demandé de
démêler tout ça en sous entendant
fortement que le boys and his mme et les
lois des probabilités sont cruciales
pour y arriver
aujourd'hui on va parler justement des
lois des probabilités en insistant en
particulier sur l'équation qui est sans
doute la plus importante à savoir la
formule deux pays''
et du coup il va y avoir des équations
mathématiques mais rassurez vous rien de
très compliqué bon ils ont rien de trop
compliqué pour illustrer la formule de
bise
prenons le cas d'une journée classique
où il peut pleuvoir nom et où je peux
avoir pris mon parapluie ou non donc
dans l'ensemble des journées imaginable
il y à un sous-ensemble pluie et un
autre sous ensembles parapluie dans le
cas général les sous-ensembles
produisent 4 régions différentes
il est possible en fonction de leur
configuration que l'une des régions
disparaissent donc techniquement l'une
ou plusieurs des régions peut être vide
mais pour simplifier supposons que les
quatre régions son nom vide
quelles sont elles eh bien il ya une
région qui est dans pluie mais pas dans
parapluie ça correspond au cas où il
pleut et je n'ai pas pris mon parapluie
et samui
on peut appeler cette région pluie et
non parapluie dans sept autres régions
il pleut et j'ai mon parapluie c'est
donc la région puis et parapluies puis
on a cette région où il ne pleut pas
mais j'ai quand même pris mon parapluie
peut-être parce qu'il traînait au fond
de mon sac ou parce que je craignais la
pluie qui n'est jamais venue c'est la
région non pluie et parapluies enfin il
y à la région extérieur qui correspond
au cas où il ne pleut pas et je n'ai pas
pris mon parapluie ce qu'on vient de
dessiner là c'est ce qu'on appelle un
diagramme de venn et ça peut être très
utile pour visualiser les différentes
choses qui peuvent se passer
ok maintenant on va rajouter une couche
de probabilités à ce raisonnement en son
bis ça va être très simple on va tout
bêtement considérer que la probabilité
d'un événement est la taille de son
ensemble ainsi si on est en bretagne
notre diagramme de venn probabiliste
ressemblera peut être à ça
et si on est sur la côte d'azur ça
ressemblera peut-être davantage à ça on
peut d'ailleurs noter notre première loi
des probabilités et calculer la
probabilité de pluie ou parapluie à
l'aide des régions identifiées
auparavant on voit que cette probabilité
se décompose en pluie et non parapluie
plus puis et parapluies plus non plus et
parapluies n'a d'ailleurs une autre
façon de compter les régions pour
obtenir le même résultat
on peut d'abord additionner pluie plus
parapluie et se rendre compte qu'on a
alors compté deux fois la région puis et
parapluies et donc pour ne l'avoir
compté qu'une fois on peut retrancher
pluie et parapluies on obtient alors
l'équation probabilité de pluie ou
parapluie est égal à probabilité de
pluie plus probabilité de parapluies -
probabilité de pluie et par a pris vous
on vient d'obtenir notre première loi
des probabilités
donc ceci dit dans le cadre en tout cas
de cette série je vous conseille de ne
pas l'apprendre par coeur parce qu'elle
n'est en fait pas souvent utiles aux
raisonnements probabiliste le mieux si
vous en avez besoin
c'est sans doute de redessiner un
diagramme de venn et de redémontrer la
formule
bref revenons à ce qui sera
incontournable pour le raisonnement
probabiliste à savoir la notion de
probabilités conditionnelles en
particulier en pratique d'autres
exemples la probabilité conditionnelle
la plus intéressante est sans doute la
probabilité d'avoir un parapluie sachant
qu'il pleut ou dit autrement s'il pleut
quelle est la probabilité que j'ai pris
mon parapluie
jetons un oeil aux diagramme de venn
s'il pleut c'est koné dans la région
pluie et qu'on peut oublier tout ce qui
n'est pas dans cette région les cas de
cette région où j'ai mon parapluie
correspondent alors à cette région ici à
l'écran or s'ils ont des zooms on voit
que cette région n'est autre que la
région puis et parapluies donc si
maintenant on rejoue on voit que parmi
tous les cas où il pleut seul ce puits
et parapluies sont ceux où j'ai mon
parapluie
du coup il semble naturel de considérer
que lorsqu'il pleut la probabilité que
j'ai mon parapluie est la taille depuis
et parapluies relativement à tout
l'ensemble pluie eh bien on vit en fait
de donner la définition des probabilités
conditionnelles
la probabilité que j'ai mon parapluie
sachant qu'il pleut c'est égal à la
probabilité pluie et parapluies / la
probabilité pluie alors ça c'est une
définition donc ça ne peut pas être faux
mais la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est est ce qu'il s'agit d'une bonne
définition
lorsque l'on parle de la probabilité que
j'aime on parlera plus sachant qu'il
pleut s2 se calcule que l'on parle et
bien le pari fondamentale du bail à nice
mme c'est que non seulement la réponse à
cette question est à peu près oui mais
surtout que la réponse serait clairement
oui si on réfléchissait mieux à cette
question autrement dit le bdia nisme
c'est faire du langage des probabilités
le langage du savoir tout le reste est
alors secondaire ou erronées ok mais
qu'est ce que la formule de bay dans
tout ça et bien reprenons notre
définition des probabilités
conditionnelles en multipliant par la
probabilité de pluie des deux côtés on
voit que la probabilité de puits et
parapluie est égale à la probabilité de
pluie fois la probabilité de parapluies
sachant pluie et à bien y réfléchir
c'est une équation de très naturel pour
qu'il y ait pluie et parapluies bas il
faut d'abord qu'ils aient pluie mais
alors on sait qu'il ya pluie et du coup
on se place dans un cadre conditionnée
par la présence de pluie et donc il nous
faut considérer la probabilité de
parapluies conditionné à la présence de
pluie et ce qui est maintenant
intriguant c'est qu'on peut faire le
même raisonnement mais avec l'autre côté
du diagramme c'est à dire en inversant
le rôle de pluie et parapluies et oui de
même la probabilité de puits et
parapluies c'est la probabilité de
parapluies fois la probabilité de pluie
sachant par appui et maintenant ce qui
est fascinant c'est qu'on a réussi à
calculer la région centrale de deux
manières différentes
résonant avec la partie de gauche ou la
partie de droite du diagramme du coup on
en vient à l'égalité probabilité de
pluie fois probabilité de parapluies
sachant pluie est égale à la probabilité
de la région centrale pluie et
parapluies et c'est aussi égal
la probabilité de parapluies fois la
probabilité de pluie sachant parapluie
division maintenant par la probabilité
de parapluies des deux côtés et voilà
alors par habitude je préfère inverser
l'ordre des multiplications à droite ça
change absolument rien et ça m'aide pour
la mémorisation de cette formule de
toujours les clercs de la même manière
et je me suis habitué à cette manière on
obtient alors la fameuse formule de pays
celle ci nous dit que la probabilité
conditionnelle probabilité de pluie
sachant parapluie se déduit d'un calcul
et ce calcul est probabilité de
parapluies sachant pluie fois
probabilité de pluie / la probabilité de
parapluies ça y est vous connaissez la
formule deux pays
vous pouvez donc entrer dans mon bureau
alors ce n'est pas tout à fait finie en
effet bien souvent en pratique surtout
dans le cadre du parisianisme sur le
mono fist le dénominateur de la formule
de droite n'est pas donné et en fait il
est utile de le décomposer en les causes
qui ont conduit ici dans notre cas vous
faites que j'ai mon parapluie
dans notre cas on peut identifier deux
situations où j'ai mon parapluie
soit il pleut j'ai pris mon parapluie
soit il ne pleut pas et j'ai pris mon
parapluie en calculant ensuite chaque
terme via la formule des probabilités
conditionnelles ou n'obtient finalement
la loi dite des probabilités total cette
loi dit que la probabilité d'un
événement ici parapluie se décompose
pour la somme des probabilités des
scénarios qui conduisent à cet événement
où l'art ça commence à faire beaucoup
d'équations tout ça mais ne vous
inquiétez pas pas besoin de retenir les
détails pour l'instant je veux juste en
arriver à l'équation finale
remplaçant le dénominateur de la formule
deux pays'' à l'aide de la loi des
probabilités total on obtient enfin la
version que je préfère de la formule
deux pays
enfin pas encore tout à faire faisons un
peu de cosmétiques pour embellir encore
un peu plus cette équation
tout d'abord en maths on déteste le
particulier et on adore généralisée con
c'est possible est ici clairement notre
raisonnement n'est pas spécifique à
l'appui et à mon parapluie
donc on va remplacer ces deux événements
par deux lettres abstraite
d été est plutôt que non t on va appeler
à l'alternative à thé et dernière chose
en général il n'y a pas une seule
alternative à t il peut même y avoir une
infinité d'alternative à thé par chance
la loi des probabilités total s'adapte
parfaitement à ce cas elle revient tout
simplement à prendre la somme sur toutes
les alternatives possibles à thé qui ont
conduit à des et cette fois on y est
voici mesdames et messieurs une équation
préféré des mathématiques
voici la formule de pez dans sa plus
jolie forme voici l'équation que je me
permets d'appeler sans sourciller la
formule du servoir alors si vous n'avez
pas tout suivi surtout ne vous inquiétez
pas on consacrera la prochaine vidéo à
décortiquer cette merveilleuse équation
il faut du temps et même beaucoup de
temps pour vraiment la comprendre et la
saisir au plus profond de son âme
mais en attendant la semaine prochaine
je peux d'ores et déjà insisté sur un
détail pas si anecdotique le choix des
lettres d été est en fait loin d'être
anodin des correspond aux données
étaient aux théories et ce que nous dit
la formule du savoir c'est que pour
déterminer la probabilité d'une théorie
sachant toutes sortes de données
collectées il faut et il suffit
d'effectuer ce calcul est toute
alternative est selon la pure bayésienne
irrationnelle en particulier cette
merveilleuse équation a des conséquences
absolument stupéfiante comme le fait que
le raisonnement intuitif le raisonnement
logique et le raisonnement hypothético
déductive sont au mieux un complet voire
tout simplement erroné voire juste
complètement fallacieux et ça on ne
développera tout au long de cette série
mais je vous invite vivement réfléchir à
cette formule a essayé de découvrir par
vous même c'est implication stupéfiante
notamment au hasard lorsqu'on l'appliqué
à l'énigme des deux enfants l'anr fois
je vous ai posé l'énigme des deux
enfants et il ya eu énormément de
réactions dans les commentaires
et l'une des critiques les plus
récurrentes consiste à dire que le
problème tels que je les pose est est un
problème mal posé et ça c'est bizarre
quand vous y réfléchissez après tout le
prime telles que je les pose et n'a rien
de très étrange vous parle d'un an
qui a deux enfants et l'un d'eux est un
garçon qu'elle a profité que l'autre
soit un garçon aussi ça paraît pas
insensé que de poser le problème comme
cela en particulier ça peut largement
avoir des conséquences pratiques par
exemple imaginons qu'on soit maintenant
invité à l'anniversaire de l'autre
enfant où on peut vouloir changer l'idée
de cadeau qu'on a en tête en fonction de
si l'on croit que l'autre enfant est
probablement un garçon ou une fille du
coup c'est une question qui quand même à
une certaine pertinence pratique alors
peut-être que dans sa forme tels que
j'ai posés là pas directement une
application pratique mais il me semble
que c'est assez facile d'imaginer des
variantes qui ont des implications
pratiques et pour lequel il semble utile
d'avoir en tout cas une estimation de la
probabilité que l'autre enfant soit un
garçon
en tout cas si vous y réfléchissez en
pratique des variantes de ce problème en
pratique y en a énormément
généralement quand vous parlez un ami
que vous avez pas vu depuis 10 ans et
vous savez qu'il a deux enfants
vous n'êtes pas du tout sûre du sexe de
ses enfants et vous pouvez vouloir
essayer d'estimer cette probabilité à
partir d'informations que vous avez
collecté et si l'une de ces informations
c'est le fait que l'un des enfants est
un garçon si vous voulez savoir le
segment bas il paraît pas débile
d'essayer de chercher à raisonner et
finalement les raisonnements seront
peut-être pas si différent du
raisonnement qu'il faut avoir dans ce
problème et là on rentre vraiment dans
un truc assez bizarre du pays' yanis va
savoir que point bas les uns il faut
toujours parié donc on n'est pas sûr du
sexe de l'enfant mais si je vous propose
des cotes pour parier sur le sexe de
l'autre enfant va si c'est une cote à 1
contre 1 est-ce que vous pariez ci sert
à deux contre un à ce moment marié dit
c'est une cote à 7 contre 5
est-ce que vous parlez je pense que ce
sont des questions qui se pose est en
tout cas la pure bavaisienne pense que
largement des questions qui se posent
mais pour ceux qui sont vraiment pas à
l'aise avec ces idées qui du coup sont
absolument probable il ya un moyen de
rendre sa question un peu plus concrète
est typiquement c'est ce qu'a fait
amicale honnête dans un super à son âge
rendent une super idée de sondages où il
a posté ce tweet avec deux réponses
possibles puis aux garçons donc dans ce
tweet il vous demande de penser à une
personne de votre entourage qui a deux
enfants dont l'un est un garçon qu'il
est alors le sexe de l'autre enfant
michael vous demande
de répondre garçon ou fille et ensuite
il a collecté les données sur pas mal de
gens et il ya eu plus de 2000 votes
vraiment pas le vote
on peut faire des intervalles influencé
tous ces résultats vraiment très
intéressant et il ya eu une réponse
ce que je vous conseille c'est de ne pas
aller voir la réponse vous pouvez aller
voir chercher sur google peut trouver
facilement mais le meilleur truc encore
à faire c'est de ne pas aller voir les
résultats et d'essayer de prédire
quelles seraient les résultats d'après
vous qu'est ce qui ressort de ce truc
est ce que c'est un tir garçons de tir
fuit ou est-ce que c'est 50-50 exprimé
cette idée c'est de l'écrire quelque
part pour vraiment affirmer que c'est
vraiment votre prédiction maintenant et
puis vous pourrez ensuite aller voir les
résultats du sondage et constater si
votre prédictions étaient justes
plus généralement sur ce problème vous
demande de faire attention à votre excès
de confiance et énormément de réponses
dans les commentaires qui donnait
clairement une réponse et rejeter
l'autre sans arguments très solides et
avec un certain excès de confiance voire
une moquerie de la réponse opposée
voilà le problème est vraiment vraiment
subtil j'essaie de montrer ça je peux
pas mal insisté sur le fait que moi
personnellement c'est un truc que j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup de mal à comprendre
j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
comprendre et je pense aujourd'hui mieux
gérer facilement 6 ans pour y arriver
c'est un panneau vraiment vraiment
difficile donc vous demande vraiment
être prudent et d'envisager la
possibilité que vous vous trompiez
peut-être quelle que soit la réponse à
laquelle vous pensez et plus
généralement avec ce genre de problème
ce qui est vraiment génial c'est
attendre la réponse à ce problème la
limite la réponse on s'en fout ce qui
est vraiment intéressant c'est de
comprendre le problème de le tourner
dans tous les sens et d'explorer toutes
ses différentes variantes vraiment ce
problème sera ce que vous en fleuret si
vous voulez considérer qu'il est pas
intéressant vous pouvez juste le jeter
c'est vraiment dommage je pense parce
que vous passerez à côté de quelque
chose d'assez rare dans les yeux au lieu
de cela ce que je vous encourage
beaucoup plus à faire c'est de
considérer qu'il ya vraiment un truc
intéressant dans ce problème un truc
mystérieux et que ça vaut le coup de
bien réfléchir pour essayer de mieux
comprendre les mystères que renferme
cette énigme bref soyez pas un mec
autant et condescendant guider pas très
très mal essayé plus d'être un
explorateur qui pose des questions
intéressantes
elle espère que j'avais mais cette vidéo
la prochaine on a dit c'est fait encore
un peu plus cette formule le dub et
j'essayais de la coupe on allait devoir
ce qu'elle dit notamment par rapport à
l'épistémologie pj parisienne si j'ai
aimé c'est évidemment celle de laquelle
le commentaire je partage et pensez à
vous abonner pour en parler
l'épisode version cooper power dont et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois admettons que vous êtes convaincu à
100% de la trémie vous est absolument
certain que la météo un tribunal dans
quelle mesure êtes-vous prêt à
transférer ce degré de conviction sur la
conclusion qu'il va pleuvoir demain la
météo a généralement raison elle peut
parfois se tromper tenant compte de tout
cela convaincu à 100% de la prémisse
vous serez peut-être vaincu à 90% de la
conclusion et c'est déjà pas mal le lien
est plutôt fort si dans un certains
échantillons
il ya une certaine proportion d'éléments
qui ont la propriété à et une autre
proportion d'éléments qui ont la
propriété
b on peut calculer la proportion des
éléments qui ont les deux propriétés à
la fois ainsi on prend le pourcentage
des éléments qui sont à lyon multiplie
par le pourcentage de ceux qui sont b
parmi ceux qui sont déjà à et puis on
peut faire aussi l' inverse on prend le
pourcentage des éléments qui sont ou b
et on multiplie par le pourcentage de
ceux qui sont à parmi ceux qui sont déjà
du coup on a cette égalité
voilà c'est par où ce en vérité c'est
plutôt pierre simon laplace qui quelques
années plus tard à coup pris le
véritable intérêt de cette égalité en
effet en la réécrivant plus tôt ainsi il
remarque que elle peut servir à
retourner les probabilités
conditionnelles
c'est à dire trouver la probabilité de
bsh en a
à partir de la probabilité de à la
chambre et ça c'est fondamental